hi guys I'm Eric Boston we've been
seeing a lot of new footage from Logan
lately a spot during the Superbowl few
other TV spots and an amazing one-minute
scene from somewhere in the middle of
the movie and I know we just did a
breakdown on the last full Logan trailer
and you should definitely check that out
but there's a lot of cool stuff in this
new footage that I wanted to quickly
point out for you guys so let's get
started with that Super Bowl spot titled
great
[Music]
okay so some of you pointed out my last
trailer breakdown that Logan isn't just
cutting himself here he's pulling out
one of his claws and yes that's true
Logan's claws are clearly breaking down
on him just like the rest of his body
but I still think this scene is meant to
show Logan hurting himself as well I
think the next shot after this is going
to show him looking at his other hand
and being surprised at how the cut on
his palm still isn't healing now I like
the choice to use Amazing Grace here it
Mason graces a song that expresses the
theme of redemption which reflects on
what looks to be Logan's arc in this
movie a wretch who saved by this stray
girl that he learns to love kind of like
a loose a food situation but really
Amazing Grace is a common song at
funerals so I don't think we're meant to
feel that hopeful about the characters
here both of the shots of Logan crawling
on the ground and Charles Xavier
convulsing look like these men could be
at the moment of their death other new
interesting shots here Donald Pierce
screwing on his cybernetic hand I like
the idea that that's something he'll be
able to attach and swap out with other
part kind of like a mercenary Captain
Hook there's also a new shot of Stephen
Merchant
as Caliban now we haven't seen much of
him since the first trailer remember
he's a mutant with the ability to track
down the location of other mutants we
actually saw a different version of that
character briefly in x-men apocalypse
now Caliban is flicking the pins out of
grenades and I gotta say he really
reminds me of Heath Ledger's Joker here
like imagine him saying oh now I don't
know if he plans on throwing these or
using them to escape or if he actually
intends on blowing himself up but it's a
real badass move that I'm interested to
see merchants take on the character now
the final interesting shot from this
trailer is another angle of Laura
running in the woods and now we see a
bunch of other kids running along with
her and I'm thinking that those might be
other escaped mutants may be from the
same transit jet lab that x-23 escaped
from or some other new location like
maybe this movies third act will involve
freeing a bunch of mutant kids from like
a mutant dogfighting ring not sure but
let's move on to this next TV spot
titled his time has come
the world is not the same as it was you
they're gonna walk yeah who does she you
know she's Arlen she fell where we going
something's happening to you Logan
you're not feeling that's right
oh man
Logan okay so really there's only two
interesting new things that I saw here
one was Charles saying where we are
going there are more of them and I
assume he's referring to Butte ins here
like maybe this line is response to
Logan's line the first trailer a world
is not the same as it was their gun
where we going and those other mutants
could be referring to those other two
dudes that they shack up with on the
other trailers or all those kids we saw
running in the great spot the other big
thing was this exchange between Caliban
and Logan and I can't tell where exactly
Calvin is right here or whether this
line is meant as Caliban being worried
about Logan's fading powers or taunting
him about them now I mentioned in my
first trailer breakdown that Caliban
mutant tracking ability might be being
used against his will like transition or
the Reavers and slaving him and
exploiting his powers kind of like a
mutant divining rod and I still think
that could be the case and I love Logan
saying this line PLAs right oh man
obviously old man is a wink to the old
man Logan comics that this movie is
inspired from and this shot of Logan in
particular looks exactly like that
comics version of the character okay
there's another TV spot titled attitude
but it's mostly recycled footage from
other trailers except for one short clip
at the end so let's take a look you can
learn to be better better than me
actually yes okay so the key word in
this exchange is better so do Charles
and Logan mean better as in a better
warrior or better as in a better more
controlled person who makes selfless
choices and not the wild animal that
they both started out as I'm guessing
it's a second and I think this is
Charles's way of saying hey don't get
too ahead of yourself Logan you're one
spilled beer away from going Cujo and
everything with a pole to yourself okay
the new footage that I was most excited
to see was this one minute scene from
somewhere in the middle of the movie Fox
released it this week calling it you
know the drill a to mr. Martin you
understand you're trespassing right now
right so have an evening with the
previous owner
previous being the operative word it was
this the guy couldn't even get back in
your nice truck
go play okey [ __ ] come around I call
looks like mr. Martin Harrison muscle
looks that way
it's a friend of mine friend with a big
mouth I hear that a lot
and you probably hear this too oh then
I'd like and you know the drill
I will count to three and you're going
to start walking away at rights to this
one I have a lawyer now - you know the
drill
the hele so if the rest of the movie is
like this scene Logan is going to be
awesome
this scene has the look in the feel of a
modern Western with elbows threatened
each other with shotguns - get off my
property this aesthetic is similar to
movies like No Country for Old Men or
movies that came out this year like hell
or high water or nocturnal animals or
the Clint Eastwood movie the gauntlet
which director James Mangold actually
mentioned as one of the three movies
that inspired him here along with the
wrestler and Little Miss Sunshine also
if you listen closely here we get a name
for Erik lassalle's character who still
a bit of a mystery from the first
trailer a dimension awesome so the only
Morrison from the x-men comics that I
know of is Grant Morrison the prolific
comic writer he wrote the new x-men
comic series in the 2000 so this guy
seems like a new character and I'm still
not sure whether he's a mutant or not
but given the fact that he is living off
the books on someone else's land it
seems like he's in hiding maybe because
he's a mutant in a time when mutants are
being hunted down okay that covers all
the new footage we've seen for Logan and
at this point we're probably better off
not trying to predict every scene the
movie and it said just let our hype
sustain us until the movie comes out but
let me know what you think about this
new footage and what you're most excited
about for Logan in the comments and be
sure to check out my other two Logan
trailer breakdown and if you like this
video please hit like and subscribe to
new rock stars and if you really like us
you can contribute to us on patreon big
thanks to all of our current patrons you
guys are all amazing you can hit me up
on Twitter a TA box with any thoughts or
theories you have about
logan or follow new rockstars on twitter
at new rockstars for updates on our
videos alright thanks for watching bye
[Music]